create a picture graph to show how many
wands each fairy owns so glenda owns two
wands tink owns three wands mary owns
four wands and gracie owns five wands
and in our picture graph each picture of
a wand represents one wand it is equal
to one wand it means one wand alright so
glenda has two wands so let's see i'll
click one two ones for glenda
tink has three wands
so i'm gonna have one two three ones for
tink
mary has four wands so i'll have one two
three
four wands for mary
and then gracie has five wands
so i'm gonna have one two three
four
five ones for gracie
let me check my answer
let's keep going this is this is
actually a lot of fun
the zookeeper measured four penguins
their heights were 40 44 48 and 48
centimeters
make a line plot of their heights
so a line plot we have a number line
here and we want to put a dot at as many
dots as we have at a at a certain
measurement so we have one penguin that
it was 40 centimeters so at 40 we have
one penguin right over there
we have another penguin that's at 44
centimeters so we put 44 right over
there
and then we have two penguins at 48
centimeters so we could put two dots
right over there two penguins at 48
centimeters so there you go that is our
line our line plot let's keep going this
is a lot of fun
there are five books on the shelf the
heights of the books are 32 36 38 32 and
35 centimeters
make a line plot of the heights
so let's see
there is one book that is 32 centimeters
then there is a book that is 36
centimeters
then there is a book that is
centimeters 38 centimeters then there's
another book that is 32 centimeters so
we actually have two books two books one
two books that are 32 centimeters and
then one book that is at 35. so there
you go i made the line plot and remember
all a line plot is is it's essentially
counting how many of each height we have
we have two at 32 centimeters one at 35
centimeters one at 36 and one at 38.
let's do one more of these
robinhood measured four arrows the
lengths were 26 26 23 and 25 centimeters
make a line plot of the lengths
so we have two arrows that were 26 that
were 26 centimeters so under on 26 on
our number line here i'm gonna put two
dots
we have an arrow that's 23 centimeters
so i'll put one dot there
whoops and then i have one arrow that is
25 centimeters so i'll put a dot there
and we're done